[موسيقى]
الدراجات السلوفينية في
هذا المعرض هي تجربة سلوفينية خضراء وذكية
مع هذا المحرك ، نريد تقديم
سلوفينيا كدولة خضراء
وكبلد ذكي
باللون الأخضر ، أردنا أن نظهر
أننا متنوعون للغاية ولدينا
60 من
الأرض مغطاة بالغابات بالأشجار ،
لدينا الكثير من البحيرات والأنهار والبحر.
الفكرة الرئيسية وراء جناحنا هي إظهار
جناحنا كواحة عائمة فوق
الماء
وهذا هو السبب في أننا مغطاة
بواجهة خضراء هذه هي
أكبر واجهة خارجية في دبي  إنه
يحتوي على أكثر من 42000 نبتة فيه
كما
رأيت عندما تدخل الجناح
إنه أخضر جدًا إنه فريد
جدًا ومستدام للغاية وهذا مستدام
لأن لدينا شركة مبتكرة للغاية
في سلوفينيا أسست
هذا المشروع الخاص المنتج الخاص
و  نهج مبتكر خاص لهذه
الواجهة ، السطح مصنوع من الخشب
ونحن مغطى بالمياه التي تمثل
غابة المياه السلوفينية والجمال الطبيعي
عندما يدخل الناس السلوفيني  جناح
في الطابق الأرضي يمكنهم رؤية
الساحة الأوروبية وعلى الجانب الآخر
لدينا ما يسمى بالجدول التفاعلي
حيث يمكن للأشخاص الاختيار من بين 12
موضوعًا مختلفًا
ويمكنهم مشاهدة فيلم حول
مواضيع مختلفة ، وهناك موضوعات
متعلقة بالإنجازات الرياضية و
للسياحة في سلوفينيا ،
فلدينا
الطابق الأول حيث لدينا غرفة خضراء
وأنيقة في كلتا الغرفتين ، لدينا فيديو مدته سبع دقائق
على أحد الجانبين عن سلوفينيا الخضراء
والجانب الآخر عن سلوفينيا الذكية
[الموسيقى
] الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يأخذونهم  الصور من
قبل
أمام جناح
[موسيقى]
الجناح السلوفيني فريد من نوعه
يراه الناس وهذا هو رد فعل الناس
لك [الموسيقى]